ساحه بوجه بعضها البعض في تركيا مع اقتراب
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي وصفت بالطاحنه
جماهير غفيره لكل من
اردوغانو الذين حددوا سياسيهما الداخليه
والخارجيه
يختلفان في ملفات داخليه ويلتقيان في اخرى
خارجيه ليبقى ملف الوجود التركي العسكري
والاداري شمال غربي سوريا مبهما وخائبا عن
الخطابات الانتخابيه معهد الشرق الاوسط
رسم في دراسه مستقبل شمال غربي سوريا على
ضوء الانتخابات في تركيا وثلاثه
سيناريوهات قائمه بحسب المعهد في
السيناريو الاول يفوز اردوغان بولايه
جديده ويتراجع فيها عن تصريحات اشارت الى
التطبيع مع دمشق ويبقي قواته شمال غربي
سوريا وتواصل ادارته ممارسه التاثير
الاكبر في المنطقه عبر الفصائل والهيئات
التي اكلتها وتدعمها فيما السيناريو
الثاني وبصرف النظر عن المرشح الرابع
تختار الاداره التركيه الانسحاب العسكري
الجزئي من شمال غربي سوريا وتبقي نفوذها
الاداري في المنطقه مع تقليص تدخلها في
الحكم اليومي للفصائل التي تدير المناطق
وتعيد العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع الاسد ولكن
تعيق السماح له ببسط سيطرته على المنطقه
وفي السيناريو الثالث يفوز كليتش دار
اوغلو ويلتزم بما تعهد به امام الناخبين
وبالتالي يبني جدارا فاصلا على طول الحدود
مع سوريا وينسحب الجيش التركي من شمال غرب
سوريا وتفك تركيا ارتباطها بفصائل ما يعرف
بالجيش الوطني السوري
في تلك الحاله تصبح الفصائل المعارضه امام
خيارين هما اما الدخول في مواجهه مع الاسد
رغم فقدانها الدعم الاساسي او الدخول في
مصالحه معه بضمانه من وسيط كما حصل عندما
استعاد الدمشق السيطره على حلب ثلاثه
سيناريوهات اساسيه تنتظر شمال غربي سوريا
بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه انما
الثابت الوحيد هو رفض سكان تلك المنطقه
حتى اليوم العوده الى ما قبل 2011
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات